this video is brought to you by
morningbrew
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
during the dawn of the computing age ibm
was a technology giant
once dubbed big blue the scale of the
company was massive at one stage
consisting of sixty to seventy percent
of all business computers in circulation
but today it's a completely different
story
ibm was a major innovator they invented
the atm
floppy disk
hard drive
magnetic strip card
and dram to name a few
you may not also know that earlier this
year ibm after over a century of
operation has now split into two
companies
so the main question does have to be
asked why don't we all have ibm
computers and smartphones today what
happened to ibm
this is the rise and stagnation of ibm
you are watching cold fusion tv
international business machines or ibm
for short was founded in 1911.
in this year three companies the
computing scale company the tabulating
machine company and the time recording
company merged the products of ibm's
early days were quite interesting
they included electronic tabulating
machines and clocks that could record on
punch cards when workers entered work
but also stranger products like meat and
cheese slices
by the mid-1930s
ibm's electronic tabulating products
helped companies deal with huge amounts
of data so soon government began looking
to ibm services
in 1937 the us government used the
technology to keep the employment
records of 26 million americans
in a much less mundane and tragic use of
the technology the nazis used ibm
technology to keep track of jews through
a german ibm branch
[Music]
when the horror of war was over ibm
would go from strength to strength the
company would introduce the world to the
hard disk drive the 305 ramak
it stored a total of 5 megabytes but it
looked like this
yes it had to be moved with forklifts
and transported by cargo planes
the data was stored on large spinning
platters that retrieved the information
with a magnetic arm
in the same year the company would
demonstrate the earliest practical form
of artificial intelligence arthur l
samuel of ibm's new york lab programmed
an ibm 704 that could play checkers but
not only this it could learn from its
own experience
sure it was primitive but it showed that
it was possible for computers to learn
before this nobody knew if this was
truly possible
in the 1960s ibm partnered a lot with
nasa including the 1969 moon mission and
the apollo guidance computers
in 1964 ibm's innovation continued with
the release of the ibm system 360.
it was a family of mainframe computers
whose product line had enough options
for both large and small firms as well
as commercial and scientific
applications
some of the most powerful models could
do 16.6 million instructions per second
and featured one megabyte of memory
the ibm 360 solved a problem that had
begun to happen in the industry
see when a company bought a new computer
they would use it until its capacity
filled up but the problem was it was
unupgradable
the company's only option was to get a
bigger system
the issue was all the software had to be
rewritten because of incompatibilities
and this was expensive
so ibm came up with a solution of making
a family of computer where all the code
worked between them without any issues
it wasn't easy though in researching for
the system ibm spent the equivalent of
40 billion dollars more than they made
in an entire year there were problems
with production and there was much
infighting within the company
many internally thought that this would
be the end of ibm
fortunately for them though the ibm 360
became a smash hit and it propelled ibm
to become the world's largest computer
company and it single-handedly caused a
steep rise in hardware sales
at this point they were the only
significant maker of computers and had a
strong monopoly in the market
going even further with their influence
over technology the company also
developed the computer language fortran
this language was the precursor to 700
programming languages that are used all
over the globe today
interestingly fortran which is the
world's oldest commercial programming
language is still being used by nasa
scientists and others at the department
of energy over 64 years after its
inception
and here's why
according to tom cloon who works at nasa
quote
fortran has exceptionally good built-in
support for numerical calculations and
array manipulation which is particularly
important for scientists and engineers
python and java are generally perceived
as being slower
with such a rich history at this point
you'd think that ibm would have gone on
to dominate the pc market i mean today
everyone should have an ibm pc in their
home and possibly an ibm smartphone in
their hand but obviously this never
happened
so what went wrong
well it all went south for ibm in the
1980s just as the personal computing
revolution was beginning to grow
with the release of the apple ii in 1977
computers went from a tool for business
and governments to a very powerful tool
for personal use overnight whole
industries were turned upside down
on the 12th of august 1981 in a
manhattan hotel ibm unveiled the
company's entrance into this new
industry
it was called the ibm pc
welcome to the exciting new world of
personal computers
as the new user of an ibm personal
computer system you now have one of the
most powerful tools modern technology
can provide
you'll learn how a microprocessor
performs most of the same functions as a
huge mainframe processor like those
found in the big ibm type systems large
corporations use
there are quite a few new keys on your
ibm personal computer that make it
different from an ordinary typewriter at
the time the press didn't really see
what all the fuss was about but as it
turned out the personal computer would
possibly be the biggest technology
revolution in a century
when thinking about software for the new
computer ibm had two choices a 24 year
old nobody called bill gates who was
recommended by a software engineer
within ibm or
gary kildoll the president of digital
research the most well-known computer
software company at the time
if you watched my special episode on the
story you would have seen how gary blew
off ibm in what would become known as
the biggest business blunder of the
century
i'll leave a link to it in the
description it's a fascinating story
that actually impacted the entire
technology world as we know it today
after the blunder ibm would choose to
partner with bill gates and his small
company microsoft would provide the
software for the ibm pc
unfortunately for ibm they made a
massive error and did not secure the
rights to the software that microsoft
was going to make for their pc
in their mind they didn't ever really
think the pc was going to amount to much
anyway but as it turned out loads of
people wanted their own computer
at first this was fine because the ibm
pc would dominate in sales
the company predicted 200 000 units in
the first year but they were doing 200
000 units per month
in its first year the ibm pc would
generate 1 billion dollars in revenue
and by 1984 the company was raking in 46
billion dollars
but the glory wouldn't last for ibm
seeing the dollar signs soon other
manufacturers would begin to make their
own computers and microsoft was more
than happy to sell their software to all
of them
and this was when disaster began to
strike for ibm why would anyone buy an
ibm pc if they can get something that's
cheaper and performs the same way
in an instant ibm's competitive
advantage was gone
computer buyers began shopping elsewhere
to stop the downward trend in 1987 ibm
would put out their own operating system
called os2 and this was to combat
microsoft
but by this stage windows had already
been out for two years
it was too little too late ibm had lost
to the monster that they had created in
bill gates their market share went from
80 in 1983 down to 20 in 1993.
to make matters worse between 1991 and
1993 the company made a net loss of 16
billion dollars
ibm's operating system os2 didn't catch
on and was eventually killed in 1995.
the managerial controls within ibm
reportedly broke down
many parts of the company no longer
delivered revenue to support the
structure of the entire firm
even a special dividend which was
usually reserved for widows and orphans
pension funds could no longer be
sustained because of the financial
decline
in this area of their history ibm proved
to be too slow in reacting to the flood
of competition
as the 20th century drew to a close
computers were trending towards becoming
smaller faster and more efficient
ibm's mainframes were fast becoming a
thing of the past mainframes were
replaced by small servers and this
crippled ibm they were in no substantial
position to cope with this change
however in the super computing world
they were still market leaders
perhaps as a marketing stunt to prove
that they weren't completely dead at the
time ibm created deep blue a primitive
ai that defeated the reigning chess
champion gary kasparov in 1997 a result
that many experts were surprised at
despite this the downward trajectory was
still happening
although ibm's thinkpad lines of laptops
would be well received it would all be
too much and ibm's pc division was sold
off to the chinese company lenovo in
2005 for 1.75 billion the ibm giant had
fallen
reluctantly ibm had to shift their
business towards building networks and
installing servers
so the question that you might be asking
yourself in this stage of the video is
what on earth is ibm doing today
[Music]
the new century for ibm was a checkered
one it could be summarized as doing a
broad range of research and refocusing
on their strength
in terms of research the company
actually holds the record for the most
annual u.s patents and this has been
going for 28 consecutive years in a row
some research of the 2000s includes
carbon nanotube transistors flexible
transistors and ai
out of all of these emerging fields
quantum computing seems like ibm's best
shot
in 2019 ibm unveiled the queue system
one the first circuit-based commercial
quantum computer
ibm provides software that can build
quantum circuits and test them on real
quantum hardware remotely clients can
then access the computer over the cloud
cern
exxonmobil and fermilab are among some
of the clients that have signed up to
use the system remotely
if you are a long-term subscriber you'd
remember how quantum computers take
advantage of some amazing physical
properties found in quantum mechanics
through manipulating these unique
properties quantum computers one day
will be able to do calculations that are
impossible to run on devices today i've
got a video on the surprising future
applications of quantum computing so
i'll leave a link below if you're
interested
ibm has partnered with some japanese
companies and they've already identified
some promising use cases
mitsubishi chemicals research team has
developed quantum algorithms capable of
understanding the complex behavior of
chemical compounds within oled displays
a research paper by the scientists
explains how this use of quantum
computers could lead to more efficient
displays requiring low power consumption
according to zednet researchers from
mitsubishi financial group have
developed quantum algorithms that could
speed up financial operations like monte
carlo simulations
optimized portfolio management and
better risk analysis could result from
this
[Music]
so what about the competition in the
quantum computing sector what are some
other companies doing the following
information is from the newsletter
morningbrew who sponsored this section
google is dropping a few billion dollars
to try and build the first ever
commercial grade quantum computer by
2029
it could solve complex problems like
creating a low co2 fertilizer
alternative millions of times faster
than a conventional computer
dario gill director of ibm research
believes that 2023 is going to be an
inflection point where the errors of
quantum computers will continue to
decrease exponentially because of
software as opposed to just the hardware
if you want to see more stories like
this and many others be sure to check
out morning brew
morning brew is a free daily newsletter
that comes in your inbox every monday to
sunday it gets you up to speed on
business finance and tech news in just 5
minutes it's completely free and takes
less than 15 seconds to subscribe
click the link in the description below
to get started
okay so back to the video before we move
to the last section here are a couple of
interesting facts about ibm
interestingly ibm chip technology made
its way into the playstation 3 and xbox
360 back in the 2000s
the company can also be accredited for
creating the very first smartphone back
in 1992
the ibm simon
i've done a whole cold fusion episode on
that one if you're interested
in 2001 the company was sued by
holocaust survivors for their technology
being used in nazi germany the suits
were eventually dropped
during the 2008 financial crisis most
companies got smashed
in terms of share price ibm fed is
significantly better than hewed packard
cisco microsoft and oracle
the growth was ignited by global i.t
services accounting for roughly six
billion dollars per year for ibm
also providing numerous software
solutions for both government and
private industry proved to be very
lucrative
in 2019 the company purchased red hat
for a staggering 34 billion dollars
red hat provides cloud storage operating
system platforms and even consulting
services
this acquisition was ibm's big bet on
cloud computing industry observers noted
that ibm is late to the cloud computing
party and it's obvious that they're
playing catch-up with these emerging
technologies they have stiff competition
with the likes of oracle google and
amazon
in october of 2020 after over a century
of operation ibm broke into two
the old ibm will now be known as kindrel
and it's going to manage the legacy
services of iit infrastructure
the new ibm will use the red hat
acquisition as a basis to build and
focus on cloud computing and ai
will it work
who knows
[Music]
so there you go that's the story of one
of the oldest computing companies in the
entire globe even though they're trying
to get their fingers in a lot of pies
currently it's clear to see that ibm are
no longer the innovators that they once
were
so what are your thoughts will they ever
catch up to the modern players such as
amazon google or oracle
time will tell if ibm will ever rise
again but it's unlikely that we'll ever
see them dominate 80 percent of any
market like they did in the early 1980s
anyways that's about it from me thanks
for watching the whole way through my
name is tagogo and i'll see you again
soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion
it's me thinking
[Music]
you